very mr rabb always a pleasure thank you
for joining us the government has found
itself this morning in a near impossible
position
held to ransom i think it's fair to say
by northern leaders
back benchers who are saying don't you
dare increase the tier that we are in
in the morning what's your next move
we'll keep talking i mean you're right
we're it's a challenging position i
think what
the people of uh manchester liverpool
london
across the country expect is all our
political leaders to work together i
think we've done that very effectively
actually
in most areas we've worked with london
we've worked with steve rotherham
in merseyside obviously we want to keep
working with andy burnham in manchester
we put a really strong economic package
in place
we're taking targeted restrictive
measures only to the extent necessary in
the local areas
in manchester we've seen cases at 470
100 000 so it is
important to take this action and that's
the way we steer through this challenge
without ending up with a national level
lockdown so we'll keep talking we'll
keep working obviously
uh in the last resort the government has
the powers to proceed in any event but
but we'd much rather work with the local
leaders if it's all possible
is that you threatening andy burnham
no no no threats um just the the facts
of life which is that we want to work
we're striving to work with all the
local leaders uh the support is there
the
the economic the financial support the
support for test and tracing in those
areas where
they're very high risk and we understand
the challenges of
of the local authorities and the local
mayors that but but that's why we've
had arrangements with sadiq khan in
london we've put in place arrangements
with steve rotherham in merseyside
it ought to be possible in manchester
and greater manchester
and uh you know i've got lots of respect
for andy burnham but i don't think we
can
i think you use the language of uh being
held to ransom or held hostage
i think that's right for the people of
manchester i don't think it's right for
the people of this country
we must be able to take targeted
measures now to avoid
uh national level restrictions or
lockdowns later
okay how much longer are you going to
give the negotiations because you know
with all negotiations there has to be a
time scale doesn't it
well i'm like i'm not directly involved
in them so i'm not going to set um
deadlines the the
the the willingness to talk and engage
and to work
with local leaders is always there we're
continuing talks with ba
with lancashire um leaders we want to
get
that deal done as well those
arrangements put in place but i think
it's incumbent on all sides
um and that's what i would i think the
that our voters are residents they'd
want the party politics to be put to one
side i do think kay it's crazy that
you've got andy burnham
resisting targeted restrictions and
localized measures
in manchester where you've got kia
stammer in london calling for a national
level circuit break
lock down for three weeks across the
board that that
that feels to me like politics in london
politics in manchester
we just want to work with all the local
leaders for the best interests of those
communities
and the country at large i think andy
bonham said he would be happy with the
three-week lockdown
it's when it becomes the parrot
disparity between the north and the
south
that he is unhappy with how close are we
to a circuit breaker or whatever you
want to call it
circuit breaker or whatever you want to
call it well just let's look at that for
a second
that's that's crazy to say that we were
that one area would take restrictions
but only if the rest of the country
also has those restrictions when if you
look at manchester
the cases are 470 per hundred thousand
where they're much much lower and the
risk is much lower
elsewhere it can't be right to say well
we'd only have um
those restrictions in in our area uh if
everyone has to when the the challenge
and the problem isn't the same
everywhere
so but but you ask about a national
lockdown we want to avoid it
we think that kierstarmra is obviously
looking for the politics of this
but i think the right thing both on
public health grounds but also
supporting the economy
small jobs livelihoods supporting our
society the most vulnerable in it is to
avoid
a second national lockdown the way to do
it is with the tiered approach
that we've advocated that will only work
the scientists tell us
if everyone really leans in and
implements it to the maximum
that's what we hope all the local
leaders will do and everyone
at home will do as well i'm glad you
mentioned the scientists um as far as
test and trace is concerned the world
health organization's special envoy for
global covid that's dr david nabara i'm
sure you're aware of his work he's often
on the programme
the uk should see that it's in the
bottom of the league table
when it comes to test and trace and it's
a shambles
well it's just not true if you look at
our testing rate
you know forget the commentary the rate
it is
uh the best per capita in europe um
we're we're learning all the time with
it uh with the testing and tracing
uh the dynamic but it's been effective
uh in many ways and we want to get the
capacity up
even higher to 500 000 tests per day by
the end of the month um we'll take all
advice but it's not true to say
we're bottom of the of the of the league
because if you look at the testing rate
per capita
we're ahead of uh any country in europe
heading the wrong way though isn't it
during the
week ending 7th of october test and
trace reached 62.6 percent of people the
week before
it was almost 70 percent
it does evan flow a bit and there are
various different technical reasons and
local reasons
for that but um one of the advantages of
taking a localized
approach is that we can learn from what
works most effectively and actually i
pay tribute to the local councils
they've done a great job
with the testing and tracing which is
why one of the things we're doing with
the
tiered approach in local areas that go
to very high risk we're giving extra
support
uh financial and and logistical support
for them to do the testing and tracing
which is
which has actually proved pretty
effective and you're giving some
advisers
uh to the government uh 25 000 pounds
a day five people are ed conway
discovered you were paying
them uh 25 000 pounds a day to work on
this
test and trace uh scheme and app thought
you told andy burnham you were strapped
for cash
i don't know those specific details but
what that shows you is how seriously
we're taking the test and tracing and
look 200 billion
pounds has been put into the economic uh
support
coming through this pandemic so the the
point i would make to andy and others is
there's a huge financial support package
to put in place but there must be limits
to that
because we've got to pay for that the
businesses have got to pay for that the
taxpayers got to pay for that
that's why the balanced approach we've
taken the targeted approach that we've
taken
is such that preserves life and and the
nhs capacity
protects the public health but also
we're keen to keep
uh and actually striving to keep all the
jobs running the business is open we've
protected 12
million jobs through this uh crisis
we're putting the support in place
but we really need local leaders to lean
into this most have i hope andy does
but we need everyone to play their role
yeah you talk about taxpayers a
five-person team of management
consultants being paid 25
000 pounds a day to work on the system
25
000 pounds a day to work on the system
come on mr rob that cannot be acceptable
well um okay i haven't seen those
specific numbers
but of course it would depend also what
is being paid for not just the people
involved but you're right to say uh test
and trace has been a resource intensive
exercise and we want to get it right
you've on the one hand given me the
criticism and the other
i've explained that the rate has been uh
well ahead of anyone in europe but we
are
absolutely striving to make it as uh
sharp as effective as possible because
we know that's one of the important
tools i'm giving you the opportunity
this morning foreign secretary to
condemn those figures
um they're from our ed conway our
economics editor you know that he's very
thorough
in his work you can see it on twitter
what the the
uh the workings behind that but 25 000
pounds a day
for management consultants you you can't
accept that as being acceptable in any
way shape or form
i've read ed's books but i haven't seen
his twitter this morning i've been
focused on
other things but we'll go away and um
take a look at that i'm sure
but the reality is we've been very
careful with targeting the funding
uh that that has been put out like the
the dhsc and the others will be able to
speak to
that specific issue but we haven't been
slow to think i'm not asking okay
okay you've not seen it i get it i know
i haven't i'm sorry i'm sorry
you've not seen a specific tweet i'm
pointing in the direction of it i'm
asking you
to comment on it as a fact it is a fact
that five people are being paid 25 000
pounds a day management consultants
whereas some other people are being
asked to have 80
as the minimum wage to live on this is
your opportunity representing the
government this morning to say
that's not acceptable
but i haven't seen the facts and so what
you're asking me to do is rely on your
presentation
there is no journalist i trust more okay
than you but i would want to look at the
very carefully see exactly what it
covered before i condemned as you
described it
what i can tell you in relation to you
ask the most vulnerable people
we've obviously put huge amount of
support and we've preserved 12 million
jobs the combination of the job support
that we're putting in and the increase
in universal credit means as
rishi soon at the chancellor said that
someone on a low wage a minimum wage
uh one of the most vulnerable people in
this crisis would still be getting with
the support we're providing
90 percent of their of their pay
we are absolutely focused on those who
have been suffering the most whether
it's from the pandemic
or whether it's from the economic and
social challenges of this crisis and
we'll continue to do so
um another couple of quick subjects that
we need to deal with not least at brexit
can you give us a cast
iron guarantee that we will get a trade
deal that we will
get a trade deal well you can't give any
cast iron deal because it depends on the
other side and i think we are
disappointed and surprised
by the outcome of the european council
the prime minister had a good
conversation with
us on delaying we were told talks would
intensify some of that language has been
left out of the european council
decision uh that was put out we've been
told that uh
it must be the uk that makes all of the
compromises and the
days ahead that that can't be right in a
negotiation so we're surprised by that
but the prime minister will be saying
more on this later today it always comes
down in the end
to fish doesn't it i remember i'm old
enough to remember the cod wars
um the uh french want to be able to fish
in our waters are we going to let them
or not
well it's not really a question whether
they'd be allowed to fish in our waters
it's a question of the extent
and the eu line and the french line is
effectively having
our fishing industries been subject to
eu rules for many years as you described
and that's had a
huge decimating impact on the fishing
industry we must keep the uk access to
our own waters
having left the eu as an independent
coastal state permanently low
that can't be right that's a that's not
so an interest that will just be haggled
away that's a point of principle
um having said that we are close there's
only two issues fisheries and the
the low so-called level playing field
issues left with goodwill on both sides
we can get there
which is why we're a bit surprised by
the outcome of the european council
that was held this week okay now i'm
devastated you've not been looking at my
twitter feed this morning but i'm sure
that you have been looking at the front
page of the times and they've got a
story
about a reported russian dis information
campaign to undermine the oxford
university uh vaccine trials what do you
know about that
well um first of all any attempt
to be using cyber attacks for either
criminal or or profit advantage by
anyone
is absolutely reckless a responsible
criminal at a time where countries
should be coming together
to come up with a global vaccine that we
can all benefit our peoples with
um uh the i've seen what astrazeneca
have said about this we fully support
astrazeneca
doing a huge effort to try and get this
virus
uh vaccine to market so that we can get
it out and get people vaccinated
really important uh innovative way
through this crisis
and we know that russia has got a track
record um in this area
uh previously we've commented and called
them out on it
um but anyone trying to basically
sabotage the the efforts of those trying
to develop a vaccine
i think are deeply reprehensible and and
it's pretty
it's unacceptable unjustified in any
circumstances
okay almost out of time just want to ask
you quickly about marcus rashford
you know of course that he's got a
petition to try to get kids who can't
afford it
to be fed when school holidays are in
place you've given him a gong
are you willing to give him the courtesy
of having this heard
discussed further in parliament
well parliament would decide what it
discussed i pay tribute to marcus
rashford he's
seems to me like a really smart young
man he's talking from at the heart
we really understand that and i
mentioned earlier the the
what we've done to make sure the very
most vulnerable in our society are
protected i think we are in a different
situation
than we were previously when he made
what was a very valuable intervention
because schools are open we've put more
money in emergency money
for local authorities precisely to deal
with these sorts of scenarios so
we'll we'll always listen to what marx
has got to say but i think we've put the
right package in place already
um and of course parliament can debate
these issues and it's quite right that
they should
okay so the fact that it's gone over a
hundred thousand which should
automatically trigger
it being uh discussed in parliament
that's going to happen yeah
well the house authorities decide those
sorts of things but look the government
doesn't control parliament
you know the uh the mps do and they'll
debate any issue that they
wish to and i'm sure uh the the they'll
be people that want to
raise the issues that marcus has raised
and we understand and look got huge
a lot of time for um for listening to
his account and his insights into this
i know he's talking from the heart um
and i i
you know we take it seriously but all
i'd say is that we put uh
you know precisely because we listen to
him first time around and we've put a
really
uh targeted careful package of of
measures in place and supporting place
for precisely the children the family
that he's speaking up for
okay uh time is against both of us i'm
going to have to let you go next time we
chat please do come into the studio it's
much more fun it's nice to talk to you
as always thank you very much indeed mr
arm thank you